para evitar el exceso de gruñidos y groserías en los próximos 17 minutos.
Esta es la primera charla que doy acerca de esta expedición,
y aunque no estábamos secuenciando genomas
o construyendo telescopios espaciales,
esta es una historia acerca de cómo lo hemos dado todo para lograr algo
que no se había hecho nunca antes.
Así que espero que encuentren algunos elementos de reflexión.
Fue un viaje, una expedición a la Antártida,
el continente más frío, con más vientos, más seco y mayores alturas de la Tierra.
Es un lugar fascinante. Es enorme.
Dos veces más extenso que Australia,
un continente que tiene el mismo tamaño que China e India juntas.
De paso quiero añadir que he imaginado
algo interesante en los últimos días,
algo que espero que Chris Hadfield pueda mencionar en TED en unos pocos años,
conversaciones del estilo:
"Oh, ¡Antártida! Impresionante.
Mi marido y yo nos fuimos a la Antártida con Lindblad para nuestro aniversario..."
O, "¡Genial! ¿Fueron allí para el maratón?"
(Risas)
Nuestro viaje fue, de hecho, 69 maratones consecutivas
en 105 días, un viaje de 3000 km ida y vuelta a pie, de la costa antártica
al Polo Sur y de regreso.
Con esta marcha hemos batido el récord
del viaje polar a pie más largo de la historia
por más de 640 kilómetros.
(Aplausos)
Para quienes viven en la región de la Bahía de Vancouver,
es lo mismo que caminar desde aquí hasta San Francisco
y luego dar la vuelta y volver caminando.
Visto como un viaje de campamento fue uno de los largos,
y uno que he visto resumido sucintamente aquí
en las benditas páginas de Business Insider Malasia.
["Dos exploradores acaban de terminar una expedición polar
que mató a todos los que lo intentaron la última vez"]
Chris Hadfield habló elocuentemente
sobre el miedo y sobre las posibilidades de éxito,
y de hecho las probabilidades de sobrevivir.
De las 9 personas que habían intentado
hacer este viaje antes que nosotros,
ninguna llegó al Polo y regresó,
y 5 murieron en el intento.
Este es el capitán Robert Falcon Scott.
Lideró el último equipo que intentó esta expedición.
Scott y su rival Sir Ernest Shackleton,
dirigieron, por una década,
expediciones donde se disputaron
el puesto de llegar primero al Polo Sur,
para trazar y cartografiar el interior de la Antártida,
un lugar del que, por aquel entonces,
se sabía menos que de la superficie de la Luna,
que podíamos ver a través de telescopios.
La Antártida era, en su mayor parte, hace un siglo, un terreno inexplorado.
Algunos conocen la historia.
La última, la Expedición Terra Nova de Scott del 1910,
comenzó como una gran aventura al estilo asedio.
Tenía un gran equipo que utilizaba ponis,
perros, tractores con motores de gasolina,
que programaba y enterraba depósitos de alimentos y combustible
con la ayuda de los cuales su último equipo de 5 hombres llegó al Polo,
para luego volver y regresar a la costa esquiando y a pie.
Scott con su equipo de 5 hombres
llegó al Polo Sur en enero de 1912
para descubrir que había sido vencido por el equipo noruego de Roald Amundsen
que montaba en trineos de perros.
El equipo de Scott viajaba a pie.
Y durante más de un siglo este viaje ha quedado sin terminar.
El equipo de 5 hombres de Scott murió en el viaje de vuelta.
Y durante la última década,
había estado preguntándome por qué.
¿Cómo es que este desafío seguía sin superarse?
El equipo de Scott cubrió más de 2500 km a pie.
Nadie se ha acercado a esta distancia desde entonces.
Así que ese era un reto para la resistencia humana, el esfuerzo humano,
un logro deportivo, sin duda en el clima más inhóspito de la Tierra.
Era como si el récord de la maratón
hubiera permanecido imbatible desde 1912.
Y, por supuesto, una extraña y predecible combinación de curiosidad,
terquedad, y probablemente, arrogancia,
me llevaron a pensar que podría ser el hombre adecuado para terminar el trabajo.
A diferencia de la expedición de Scott, éramos solo 2 en el equipo,
que partimos de la costa de Antártida en octubre del año pasado,
transportándolo todo nosotros mismos,
un proceso que Scott llamaba "acarreo humano".
Cuando digo que era como caminar desde aquí a San Francisco y volver,
me refiero a que era como arrastrar algo
que pesaba un pelín más que el jugador más pesado de la NFL.
Nuestros trineos pesaban 200 kilos,
o 440 libras cada una, a la salida,
el mismo peso que podía llevar el más débil de los ponis de Scott.
Al principio, avanzábamos un promedio de 800 metros por hora.
Tal vez la razón por la que nadie intentó hacer este viaje hasta ahora,
durante más de un siglo,
fue que nadie había sido tan estúpido como para intentarlo.
Y aunque no puedo decir que estábamos explorando el continente
a la auténtica manera eduardiana, en el sentido de que no estábamos
dando nombre a ninguna montaña o cartografiando valles inexplorados,
creo que entramos en territorio desconocido
en lo que a la condición humana respecta.
Si en el futuro se descubre que existe un área del cerebro humano
que se ilumina cuando uno se maldice a sí mismo,
yo no me sorprendería en absoluto.
Uds. han oído que en promedio
los estadounidenses pasan el 90 % de su vida en los interiores.
No estuvimos entre 4 paredes durante casi 4 meses.
No vimos una puesta de sol tampoco.
Fueron 24 horas de luz.
Las condiciones de vida fueron bastante espartanas.
Me cambié de ropa interior 3 veces en 105 días
y Tarka y yo compartíamos menos de 3 m cuadrados de tienda de campaña.
Aunque sí tuvimos a nuestro alcance tecnología
que Scott nunca pudo haberse imaginado.
Escribíamos en nuestro blog cada noche en directo desde la tienda de campaña,
a través de un ordenador portátil y un transmisor satelital a medida,
utilizando la energía solar
del panel fotovoltaico flexible montado encima de la tienda.
Escribir era importante para mí.
De niño me encantaba la literatura de aventuras y de exploraciones,
y creo que todos hemos visto aquí esta semana
la importancia y el poder de la narración.
Así que tuvimos tecnología del siglo XXI,
pero la realidad es que los desafíos a los que Scott se enfrentó
fueron los mismos a los que nos enfrentamos nosotros:
el clima y lo que Scott llamaba deslizamiento,
la cantidad de fricción entre los trineos y la nieve.
Las temperaturas más bajas que sufrimos por el viento fueron de -55 grados
y tuvimos visibilidad cero, lo que se llama "blanco total",
durante gran parte de nuestro viaje.
Caminamos a lo largo y a lo ancho
de uno de los glaciares más peligrosos del mundo, el glaciar Beardmore.
Tiene 180 kilómetros de largo, y está cubierto en su mayor parte
por el llamado hielo azul.
Es una superficie hermosa, brillante, de color azul-acero,
cubierta de miles y miles de grietas,
profundas grietas en el hielo glacial de hasta 60 metros de profundidad.
Los aviones no pueden aterrizar aquí,
así que aquí estuvimos en situación de riesgo,
porque técnicamente, es cuando menos oportunidades de rescate teníamos.
Llegamos al Polo Sur después de 61 días de camino,
con un solo día de descanso debido al mal tiempo,
y lamento decir que sentí una especie de decepción.
Hay una base estadounidense permanente,
la Estación Amundsen-Scott South Pole en el Polo Sur.
Tienen una pista de aterrizaje, un comedor,
duchas con agua caliente,
una oficina de correos, una tienda para turistas,
una cancha de baloncesto que funciona también como sala de cine.
Así que es un poco diferente hoy en día,
y también hay hectáreas de basura.
Creo que es maravilloso
que los humanos pueden vivir allí 365 días del año
con hamburguesas y duchas de agua caliente y cines,
pero parece que también producen un montón de cajas de cartón vacías.
A la izquierda de esta fotografía, varias hectáreas de basura
a la espera de ser recogida y llevada lejos del Polo Sur.
Pero también hay un poste en el Polo Sur,
y llegamos allí a pie, sin ayuda,
sin ningún apoyo, por la ruta más difícil,
1450 km en un tiempo récord,
acarreando más peso que nadie en la historia.
Y si hubiéramos parado allí y vuelto a casa en avión,
lo que sin duda hubiera sido lo más sensato,
entonces mi charla terminaría aquí
y le pondría fin con algo como esto:
Si tienen el equipo adecuado,
las herramientas adecuadas, la tecnología adecuada,
y si tienen suficiente confianza en sí mismos y suficiente determinación,
entonces cualquier cosa es posible.
Pero luego empezamos el viaje de regreso,
y aquí es donde las cosas se ponen interesantes.
Allí estábamos, en lo alto de la meseta antártica,
a más de 3 km de altura, con mucho viento, mucho frío y sequedad, estábamos agotados.
Cubrimos una distancia de 35 maratones,
estábamos por la mitad,
y teníamos una red de seguridad, por supuesto,
con aviones de esquí y teléfonos satelitales
y balizas de seguimiento funcionando todo el día, que no existían cuando Scott,
pero en retrospectiva,
en lugar de hacernos la vida más fácil,
esta red de seguridad en realidad nos permitió
aprovechar este margen de seguridad
y viajar muy cerca de nuestros límites absolutos como seres humanos.
Es una forma muy sutil de tortura
abstenerse de comer hasta al punto de la inanición día tras día,
a la vez que se arrastra un trineo lleno de comida.
Estuve durante años escribiendo textos locuaces
en las propuestas de patrocinio,
acerca de superar los límites de la resistencia humana,
pero en realidad, estar en aquel lugar fue de hecho muy aterrador.
Antes de llegar al Polo tuvimos
dos semanas con el viento de cara, lo que nos retrasó.
Como resultado, pasamos varios días comiendo solo media ración.
Teníamos una cantidad finita de alimentos disponibles en los trineos para este viaje
así que tratamos de resolverlo reduciendo el consumo de calorías a la mitad.
Como resultado, nos volvimos hipoglicémicos,
los niveles de azúcar en la sangre disminuyeron día tras día,
y nos volvimos cada vez más sensibles al frío extremo.
Tarka tomó esta foto de mí una noche
tras casi desmayarme por hipotermia.
Los dos sufrimos ataques recurrentes de hipotermia
algo que no había experimentado antes,
y era muy aleccionador por cierto.
Por mucho que a uno le guste pensar, como lo hice yo,
que es el tipo de persona que no se rinde,
que hará frente a las dificultades,
la hipotermia no te deja muchas opciones.
Uno se vuelve totalmente incapaz.
Es como ser un niño borracho.
Es patético.
Recuerdo que solo quería acostarme y dejarlo ya.
Era una extraña y peculiar sensación,
y una verdadera sorpresa para mí sentirme débil hasta ese punto.
Y entonces nos quedamos del todo sin comida,
a 75 km distancia del primer depósito
que enterramos en nuestro viaje de ida.
Disponíamos de 10 depósitos,
literalmente enterramos alimentos y combustible;
el combustible era para la cocina, para derretir la nieve y conseguir agua.
Me vi obligado a tomar la decisión de llamar para pedir provisiones
por avión, que nos trajo alimentos para 8 días para ayudarnos a cubrir esa brecha.
Tardaron 12 horas hasta que llegaron desde la otra punta de la Antártida.
Pedir ese avión fue una de las decisiones más difíciles de mi vida.
Y me siento como quien ha hecho trampa
y está aquí luciendo tripa.
He engordado 13 kilos en las últimas tres semanas.
Esa hambre me ha dejado una cicatriz mental muy interesante,
por eso estoy aspirado cada bufete de hotel que puedo encontrar.
(Risas)
Pero estábamos realmente hambrientos y en bastante mal estado.
No me arrepiento de la llamada por un segundo,
porque estoy aquí con vida,
con todos los dedos intactos, contando esta historia.
Pero recibir ayuda externa nunca fue parte del plan,
y es algo con lo que mi ego todavía está luchando.
Este había sido el sueño más grande que había tenido,
y era casi perfecto.
En el camino de regreso a la costa,
los crampones —los picos de las botas de hielo
que teníamos para cruzar el hielo azul del glaciar—
se rompieron en la cima de Beardmore.
Nos quedaban 160 kilómetros cuesta abajo
por este hielo azul duro como una piedra y muy resbaladizo.
Teníamos que repararlos casi cada hora.
Para que se hagan una idea del tamaño,
esta es la vista a la boca del glaciar Beardmore.
Todo Manhattan podría caber en la brecha que se ve en el horizonte.
Hay 30 kilómetros entre el Monte Hope y el Monte Kiffin.
Nunca me he sentido tan pequeño como en la Antártida.
Cuando llegamos abajo, a la boca del glaciar,
encontramos nieve fresca cubriendo las decenas de grietas profundas.
Uno de los hombres de Shackleton describió este tipo de terreno al cruzarlo
como como caminar sobre el techo de cristal de una estación de tren.
Caímos por ellas más veces de lo que puedo recordar,
con solo poner un esquí o una bota en la nieve.
De vez en cuando caíamos y nos hundíamos hasta los hombros
pero por suerte nunca más profundo que eso.
Y hace menos de 5 semanas, después de 105 días,
cruzamos esta línea de meta extrañamente desfavorable,
en la costa de la isla de Ross
en el territorio de Nueva Zelanda en la Antártida.
Se ve el hielo en primer plano
y como rocas desmoronadas al fondo.
Detrás de nosotros, una ininterrumpida pista de esquí de casi 2900 kilómetros.
Habíamos hecho el viaje polar más largo realizado a pie,
algo con lo que habíamos soñado durante más de una década.
Y mirando hacia atrás,
aún mantengo todas las cosas
que he estado diciendo en los últimos años
acerca de la importancia de los objetivos,
la determinación y la confianza en uno mismo,
pero admito que no me había fijado lo suficiente
o pensado en lo que sucede
cuando se llega a la meta que uno se propuso,
a la cual ha dedicado la mayor parte de su vida adulta,
y, de hecho, todavía estoy tratando de averiguarlo.
Hay muy pocos signos superficiales de lo que he estado haciendo.
He engordado 13 kilos.
Tengo unas cicatrices muy pequeñas, quizás cubiertas ahora de maquillaje,
una en la nariz, una en cada mejilla, por donde tenía las gafas,
pero por dentro, de hecho, soy una persona muy diferente.
Sinceramente,
la Antártida me desafió y me aleccionó tan profundamente
tanto que no estoy seguro de que jamás pueda describirlo con palabras.
Todavía estoy intentando conectar mis pensamientos.
Que estoy aquí contando esta historia
es una prueba de que todos podemos lograr grandes cosas,
a través de la ambición, a través de la pasión,
por pura terquedad,
por negarse a renunciar,
y porque si sueñas con algo lo suficiente, como dijo Sting,
de hecho aquello puede volverse realidad.
Pero también estoy aquí parado diciendo, ¿han oído
este cliché acerca de que el viaje, es más importante que el destino?
Hay algo de verdad en eso.
Cuanto más me acercaba a mi meta,
a esta costa rocosa de la isla de Ross,
más me daba cuenta de la gran lección
que me enseñó este viaje muy largo y muy duro.
La felicidad no está en la meta,
y para nosotros, los seres humanos,
la perfección con la cual muchos parecemos soñar
es algo que puede que nunca se alcance verdaderamente,
y que si no podemos sentirnos felices aquí, hoy,
ahora, en nuestros viajes,
en medio del desorden y del caos que todos habitamos,
los asuntos abiertos, las listas de tareas pendientes a medio acabar
las cosas que se pueden hacer mejor la próxima vez,
entonces tal vez nunca llegaremos a sentir la felicidad.
Mucha gente me pregunta, ¿qué sigue?
Ahora mismo estoy muy feliz
recuperándome y disfrutando de los bufetes de hotel.
Pero como Bob Hope dijo,
me siento muy humilde,
pero creo que tengo la fuerza de carácter para luchar contra ello. (Risas)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)